[Music]
if you were me would you rather live in
legrand or new york city i happen to
love lagrange so
uh-uh what does legrand have exactly
nothing what does new york city have
it has broadway and gaga yeah lady gaga
don't do it don't do what listen to me
when i say
you're beautiful in your way because god
makes no mistakes
i'm on the right track baby i was born
this way
excuse me i didn't know you knew the
world don't hide yourself from regret
just love yourself and you're set
i'm on the right track baby i was born
this way all right we're not doing that
again
[Music]
hey dad can i talk to you for a minute
i'm getting picked on by these guys at
school
why is that because i'm not like that
there's got to be more than that why are
you like that
i'm different that's not an answer jaden
cause i'm gay we won't let nature take
its course all right it'll work itself
out you know
what it's not gonna work itself
[Applause]
hide how much it hurt to muster up the
courage to ask for help
knew before he died that you loved him
and accepted him that's what matters
i never let him know he was okay i gotta
live with that
i haven't been to the movies i decided
to walk
across america i'll talk to anybody who
is about bullying
when i told you to take a walk in it
around the block not to new york city
he told us he won't live there someday
remember i saw
right there in front of me
god queens are everywhere now can we
turn that off
that wasn't even an appetizer but i have
to deal with day in and day out well
that's because you're in everybody's
face about it i wonder where i got that
one from
there's a lot of things i've learned out
here with nobody but me for company
i still feel jaden's presence
i still got a long road ahead of me
[Music]
so
you